a manufacturing plant in central Mexico
producing automotive parts that will be
shipped across the border to the United
States
the company rips up is a preferred
manufacturer among many International
firms seeking specialized components at
a low production cost we have a very
good quality that's uh one of the
strengths we have the quality we also
have a very good personnel which is very
well trained
over the past 50 years ripsa has grown
from a small family-run business into a
global Powerhouse
apart from Automotive Parts this
manufacturing plant in Mexico City is
producing components for various
emerging Industries like renewable
energy and even Aerospace technology the
vast majority of these components will
be exported to the US and Canada among
other international buyers
at a recent Summit in Mexico City the
leaders of Canada Mexico and the U.S
pledged to ramp up economic cooperation
and strengthen North American
competitiveness
and as the U.S moves away from Chinese
manufacturing experts say this will
further Propel the trend of near Shoring
the practice of expanding Manufacturing
in countries with a close Geographic
proximity to a company's customer base
all of this is good news for companies
like ripsa which seek to expand
operations in 2023
Mexico is in a perfect position to take
advantage of a historic moment and
replace China as manufacturer for the
United States and also replace the
United States as a manufacturer for
China
according to Mexican government figures
some 400 international firms sought to
move their manufacturing operations from
Asia to Mexico in just the last year
Business Leaders like Samuel uldek
ripsa's founder say success depends
heavily on seizing opportunities for
more trade
if we manufactured exclusively for a
domestic Market it would be difficult to
survive this is why we depend heavily on
export manufacturing China Remains the
world's top manufacturing country
accounting for more than a quarter of
global manufacturing output but experts
argue that changing Trends in
globalization such as the continued rise
of near Shoring could soon put Mexico at
the Leading Edge of Global Supply chains
Al Jazeera Mexico City